adrián que más ha trascendido hasta el
momento sobre este diálogo
bueno lo que sabemos por ahora es lo que
ha publicado la agencia oficial xinhua y
ahí se juntan declaraciones de sí tan
previsibles como que el conflicto no
conviene a nadie y que hay que evitar la
confrontación con sutiles críticas a
eeuu a que se le pide que como potencia
global tiene que en voz o en más en la
solución de los conflictos aquí se ha
criticado mucho su papel se ha acusado
de crear el problema con la expansión de
la otan y también de que una vez estalló
la guerra ha tenido una conducta
irresponsable e inmoral al airear la
posibilidad de que china pudiera
proporcionar armas a rusia hay que
recordar que entre china y rúsia no hay
nada ni remotamente parecido a una
alianza militar que china siempre ha
negado la posibilidad de enviar de armas
y que en cambio se ha
propuesto como mediadora y ha defendido
la solución dialogada
el discurso de si hoy es totalmente
incompatible con el auxilio militar a
rusia y creo que ahora será interesante
escuchar la reacción de byd en si sigue
alentando las dudas como ocurrió tras la
reciente reunión
de los asesores de seguridad hayan jets
y jake sullivan o si dará por buenas las
explicaciones de si porque contradecir
lo que ha dicho el presidente chino y
que ha sido recogido en la agencia
oficial sería un asunto ya muy serio y
preocupante y que podría arruinar sin
remedio las relaciones bilaterales